zoe saldana is convincing turn as the
green-skinned alien assassin Gamora made
her an immediate fan favorite in the
guardians of the galaxy franchise and
the adopted daughter of Thanos plays a
key role in the massive superhero
crossover Avengers infinity war it takes
a lot of work to transform Saldana from
all-american actress to otherworldly
badass and it begins well before she
ever sits down in the makeup chair the
Gamora regimen there's always a certain
amount of physical preparation involved
for a major role in a Marvel film but to
reprise her role as Gamora in guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 Saldana had to go a
little above and beyond in November 2014
the actress gave birth to twins and
subsequently dropped 70 pounds after
embarking on an exercise regimen would
make Drax cry she had difficulty
bouncing back up first starting off of
simply taking walks and eventually
working up to a brutal routine of squats
planks lunges and Pilates combined with
regular cardio although she's 80% gluten
free and the leans heavily on eggs
vegetables and greens she insists she
doesn't follow a strict diet as she put
it in a 2015 Facebook post I am going to
remove the word diet from my life I'm
going to remind myself that it is not
about losing weight it is about being
healthy feeling healthy for the rest of
my life head on so Donna famously played
another colorful alien in 2009 Avatar
but in that case she got a fizzy since
her entire character was digitally
rendered so it may have come as a bit of
a surprise to saw Donna the first time
the makeup department working on
guardians of the galaxy told her but
their need to make a full cast of her
head the procedure looks pretty grueling
especially if you claustrophobic no CGI
required the head cast allows effects
artists to exercise great attention to
detail when designing gamora's facial
appliances and makeup this is necessary
because in contrast with the Avatar role
there are exactly zero
computer-generated elements to Cumorah
according to guardians to makeup
designer David White's prosthetics made
from silicone a sculpted for her cheeks
and forehead the latter of which gives
her a new brow line the pieces take two
to three hours to apply and about 30 to
45 minutes to remove her prosthetic
forehead actually has a scalp Pisa runs
underneath her wig that's right she also
has to wear a wig so that's even the
edge of her hairline and a part liner
Green of course a prosthetics Aronian
the
gaining five our job as with any paint
job so Donna gets multiple complete
coats of primer before makeup artists
get down to the business of greening her
up completely a green base comes after
the primer followed by three more layers
which are airbrush done this is done to
get as close as possible to a natural
tone it all meant a grueling five hours
in the makeup chair for the first
Guardians film but only four hours for
the follow-up we shaved off an hour from
the first movie so I appreciated that
label check surprisingly virtually all
of the brands used to turn Saldana into
Kimora are mainstream commercially
available products whiteners teams seem
to be particularly fond of mac a popular
brand that's used for both the initial
layer of primer and for the green base
as applied before the airbrushing begins
products from skin illustrator and aqua
are used for the airbrush job and her
eye shadow is a careful blend of several
Mac products her nail polishes from
sinful colors and her green lipstick is
from high-end brand Kryolan not easy
being green of course it took a great
deal of time and consideration to arrive
at the right shade of green for a
character they would also be spending a
lot of time in front of green and blue
screens white and his team needed tons
of tests to nail down the right tone and
then they were tasked with using the
array of products to faithfully recreate
that exact tone day after day for the
duration of the shoot one he describes
as multi-layered with at least three
complementary tones running through it
in addition to saw Donna's natural skin
tone if it all seems like a lot of
trouble well it is but if Marvel Studios
wants us to believe that a raccoon can
talk then it's certainly not about to
cut corners to convince us that are
stunning alien assassin can be green
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you're lifting
[Music]